Brasil despidió al rey mundial del
fútbol
miles de aficionados dieron su última
diosa peleé en un multitudinario y
sentido recorrido realizado por las
calles de Santos la ciudad que lo vio
convertirse en uno de los mejores
jugadores de la historia una familia de
parte de la familia estamos agradecidos
con todos con todos por todo el amor por
todo el cariño por el respeto
y bueno para expresar nuestra gratitud
el sentimiento más grande de nuestra
familia es la gratitud de un futbolista
es la gratitud Gracias a todos
tras 24 horas de cámara ardiente las
puertas del estadio Vila belmiro donde
jugó Pelé fueron cerradas al público
luego de que 230.000 personas acudieran
a despedirse del exjugador del Santos
incluyendo al recién posesionado
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
quien participó en una misa informal en
su honor creo que el mundo le debe mucho
a Pelé sobre todo la dignidad fue un
hombre que nació nombre negro en un país
donde los prejuicios están muy presentes
y apelé nunca le importó eso siempre
supo ser Pelé el mejor el mejor y el más
humilde
un grupo de Cadetes de la policía
militar de Sao Paulo cargo el féretro y
partió con destino al cementerio
Memorial necrópolis ecuménica que
gracias a ser un cementerio vertical
tiene vistas al Vila belmiro
no estamos despidiendo solo a nuestro
Rey estamos despidiendo a un genio
se merece todo lo que está pasando hoy
en el Santos es del Santos para el mundo
[Música]
el entierro se produjo de manera privada
para familiares y amigos aunque se
espera que su Nicho sea abierto al
público Próximamente para que sus
seguidores puedan venerar al rey del
balompié brasileño